hey what you want to bet I'll take this
last shot make it if I get the ball and
they give me the ball they pick give me
the ball
all right ladies and gentlemen it's time
now to announce the MVP of the Jordan
Rising Stars game none other then Jose
Alvarado
here to present Jose Alvarado with the
MVP trophy please welcome Melanie Harris
vice president and general manager of
Jordan North America
congratulations Jose
thank you
[Applause]
Jose come on up
congratulations we heard you call game
at the end I don't know if everyone in
this house could but on television we
heard it what was that like I mean it
was you know the confidence that these
boys behind me gave me you know they
revolved with me the whole game you know
just come out here and play and enjoy
this atmosphere you know we had an
All-Star weekend and we enjoying it so I
can't can't complaining you know D Mitch
owed me a dinner he told me if I made
that last shot uh he owed me a dinner so
that's what I really wanted right there
dinner time to cash in on the dinner
what you did oh look at this yes come on
in here again lady all right what you
did today was historic because you wore
the microphone during the game had a
conversation with Adam Candice and Jamal
while you were talking to them your team
went on a run in the first round game
how
for you talking to them during
I mean it was good
it was good and I'm gonna talk with a
guy sometimes I talk too much you know
but uh that's just my my game and um I'm
glad to be the first person and I hope
it went well it went extremely well
congratulations again thank you so much
I'm gonna talk to your coach thank you
thank you well done Jose all right